they're here to react Michael Noah's
host of the Michael Noel's show Michael
good to have you with us
Abbey good to be here all right you
listen to the DNC and that is the future
of their party that is the future of
their party I think she's a good
representative the Democrats at this
point are proudly ignorant and
thoroughly anti-israel so it makes sense
this poor girl Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
is not making a great first impression
and that is the lasting one what do we
know about her since her campaign at the
national stage she is a liar she lied
about her upbringing she pretended to be
from a poor part of the Bronx and grow
up there in reality she grew up in a
ritzy part of one of the ritziest
counties in the country I know this
because I grew up in the town over from
her so we know that and now we know that
she is proudly ignorant she has this
great line she says you know I don't
really know a lot about this but I
firmly believe you know frequently wrong
but never in doubt she uses the slogans
that we've seen from Democrats now for
the past 20 years you know we heard in
the bush-era Bush lied people died he
didn't we heard no more no war for oil
there wasn't one now we hear Trump
colluded with Russia there's no evidence
of that and the myth of Israeli occupied
Palestine which I believe is the country
east of gnarnia and west of Wakanda is
another example of that you know
Margaret Hoover in that television
program scratched just below the surface
and Ocasio Cortez had no answer she
didn't know anything all she had learned
was ideology I think apparently Yorktown
High School is not as good as we all
thought it was so by the way to your
point she went to Boston University she
says she doesn't know geopolitics in
that interview she majored in
international relations so obviously
this is something that she claims to
know a lot about kudos to Margaret
Hoover in that interview for simply
listening and following up with can you
please expand on this what what I'm
surprised by is she's done so many
interviews since this big win a few
weeks ago and yet none of this has been
exposed what does this tell you about
bigger picture the Democratic Party well
first of all it tells you that the media
are carrying water for them Margaret
Hoover has a very sort of stable sober
public affairs show she's not exactly
out to get her guests but the guests
expose themselves it
oh Casio Cortez were smart she would
have locked herself in a closet until
November the election is hers and all
she's doing is hurting herself and more
broadly what this tells us is there's a
real problem with millennial education
you know I'm the same age as Ocasio
Cortez I went to a school nearby in high
school and one aspect of that is in high
schools especially in New York in those
days the curricula told you don't worry
about studying facts don't learn names
and dates and details just learn broader
picture trends and I think that's the
ideological component that allows a
committed socialist like Miss Ocasio
Cortez dispute ignorance without knowing
the basis of the things she's talking
about yeah well this was certainly I'm
sure waking up calls she's in the hot
seat now so you can bet a lot of other
questions will be coming her way Michael
knows always good to have you with us
very early there in Los Angeles yeah be
you too